what's going on
are you guys going to the streamies
tonight
hey so if you didn't know we won a
streamy this year there's two streamies
events one are called the premiere
events that's where all the technical
awards are given out and all that stuff
and then the big event which is like
broadcast live streamed all that stuff
for like show of the year youtuber of
the year all the famous people are there
two separate events i went to the first
one and i accepted the award for best
visual effects for corridor digital
thank you uh thank you to all the people
who watch our videos it's kind of hard
in this day and age to make you know
short form content minute long that you
spend five weeks on so uh yes
it was a little nervous i was nervous
man it's like you go up there and i had
like things prepared to like say in the
event that we did win because i wasn't
really expecting to win so then i get up
and i was like
i'm gonna forget everything i intended
to say and thank my wife and my wife
only yeah thank you thanks to my wife
who puts up with those hours i know she
doesn't prefer that thanks to all the
other nominees all your stuff is super
cool
thank you
uh john peter sam and nico all the vfx
artists that have helped corridor as a
team over the last few years gabe gabe
yes thanks man this is a team effort
this isn't just me so tonight is the big
awards show and sam nico and jake and
their wives we're going to be going and
then at the last minute like today and
jake changes his mind something came up
i can't go anymore you can have both my
tickets
ah it's cool except my wife works
tonight she works night shift and she's
not going to be there so nick and i are
going instead
what's up dude it's going to be nab all
over again when you guys had to share
the bed oh
what's up
the problem is that we all came into
work today thinking it was a normal day
i dressed normally
and i have to go get my suit from home
also drop obi off at home to be able to
get to the streamies on time which start
at 4 30.
you gotta look at the beauty of this
shot oh is that a blue tie like green
shirt i got the shirt in belgium i saw
this at a storefront and i was just like
[Music]
i just like everything about hawaiian
shirts but in the form of like a formal
dress shirt
i know we should do we should do
formal fridays what if we always on
fridays just got suits on and then like
went out and drank whiskey was that nico
he says he's coming down the second
meeting i'm going to order the uber i
realize you forgot something go back
upstairs five minutes ago distracted
five minutes ago he would be there in a
minute youtube.com sam and nico thanks
to the walking dead no man's land for
sponsoring this video if you didn't know
yet the walking dead no man's land is
the official game of amc's the walking
dead it's a very influential show so
influential in fact that i've got some
legitimate concerns about nick
i actually think he thinks he is negan
it's weird he's like in a
post-apocalyptic trance or something i
mean he's wearing the jacket he's got
the
scarf thing on he's even bringing in
this bat that he keeps calling some
woman's name i i don't know
the point is productivity is down and
it's starting to affect the other guys i
can't just have a bunch of negan's
running around the studio okay it's bad
for business normally i wouldn't do this
sort of thing but it's getting out of
control so in an effort to better
understand what's happening i've went
and downloaded no man's land myself it's
a turn-based action strategy game that
just launched this month where you
battle hordes of walkers with all your
favorite walking dead heroes it also
features several new improvements and a
new game mode called the distance you
start out with a couple of survivors and
you build up your camp by enlisting more
survivors and heroes to join you you can
download the game for free using the
link below and get a nick get a negan
for free it's a special offer that's
only available now
i think i'm beginning to understand
all right this is it let's take on the
streamies thank you
i i had to spend an entire hour in an
uber but i got there on time i actually
only got there like 10 minutes after you
guys did when you get to the streamies
there's like a couple hours of just kind
of like a mixer you kind of just hang
out and get drinks and chat with other
people and there's like the whole red
carpet thing i'm i've become an expert
at gopro photography the way you do it
is you got to make sure you're connected
with the app which is really fast and it
connects instantly
and then the awards start and everyone
has to go sit down and they're at their
tables honored to share the table with
rooster teeth in
funhouse and it's all highly
choreographed because it's being live
stream so it's like hey 30 seconds till
this stream goes up everyone stop
talking sit down in your seats we are
going live in 15 seconds hey you over
there sit down this is uh it's not a
joking matter get in your seat right now
we got 10 seconds the award show opens
up and poppy comes on screen is like
streamies
yeah i thought about it and i like the
streamies
[Music]
what's a streamy
this is an award show and the streamies
are an award
sometimes i wish they i was just
dreaming
i love this
this is i dig this i can dig i can get
into this
[Music]
so yeah and sam is a big fan of poppy he
loves their music and their videos and
he realizes after seeing poppy sit back
down at her table that she is sitting
right next to our good friend shonduras
so sam immediately like starts jittering
he's like okay oh she's she's sitting
next to sean juris oh i'm going to go
get a photo i was like what he like
literally in the middle of the awards
show i think it was like during a
commercial break he literally gets up
walks down into the important section of
all the tables of stream he's sean take
the photo
he did it
who is good
yeah sean took the picture for us
that's what's so cool about going to
award shows like that is you get to hang
out with all those people you got to
meet philip defranco i i get to hang out
with him like once a year and it's
usually at the streamies or vidcon it's
like we chat for 10 minutes and then i
see him the next year
anyway we are definitely looking forward
to
next year's streamies
for best
editing slash
vlog wink wink yeah yeah
4k cameras and then 8k cameras but this
records video at 4k
it's pretty sweet
when he's done napping i have a
follow-up scene for the uber trip a
friend of ours came by earlier and he
said he has access to over 30 000 in
uber credits is it even possible to get
an uber from
los angeles to new york city like how
much do you think that costs we're
getting a couple uber drivers that are
offering to do this which would be like
a nice safe comfortable way to do it but
i think more of the comedy comes in in
that opening scene where how many uber
drivers it takes to get through before
it actually
actually somebody agrees to go to new
york you know
dude i want him he goes
no nico said since seventh grade you're
gonna wake the dragon
everyone's like watching
[Music]
[Applause]
so here's the deal this is what i've
heard uber has a limit where like every
four hours you might get a new car yeah
that's what i heard so essentially they
hand you off from first to person but
here's the maximum way what if we either
we didn't find a friend that's an uber
driver
or
i need to like register as an uber
driver if i register the tesla as an
uber driver and then we go to like some
remote place and check on the app in the
middle of the night where like no other
cars show up and then i went live as the
car and you hit trip then basically i
become the uber driver we just keep
going and if it happened to be anyone
else we cancelled the trip right and so
ultimately we convert those 30 thousand
dollars with credits into uber paying
for a road trip i don't know what
percentage the driver gets but it's more
than nothing i suppose yeah so really
interesting idea so i don't know what
the process is becoming an uber driver
but if someone became an uber driver
maybe me we could all become google
we we go we we cash out those credits
road trip is that like legal or allowed
like surely there's some sort of like
agreement where you're not allowed to do
that i mean you call if you if you hit
uber randomly and the driver shows up as
a friend of yours do you go like oh [ __ ]
i can't get in this car with you this is
illegal no that's not what i'm saying
are you saying we might be recording a
confession right now
because we are we're recording the
confession i don't know it seems legal
to me it's like it sounds pretty legal
to me too uber takes a cut of the money
the driver gets the money they want
trips they want long trips
so what part of this is really
i guess the fact that it's super credit
and not actual money part of the idea is
like finding that uber driver who's
gonna take you four hours it's a
completely different idea instead it's
it's basically
loopholing
uber into paying for your road trip
essentially so it's like the whole time
you whatever you do it's like it's all
on the uber build right you know wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
what if any time
no never mind
i was like what if anytime you have to
drive somewhere you just have your
friend uber and you just have you just
pick up this there i'm like wait no that
still costs you money
you do the tesla idea of uber and then
you also have a second car that's like
how many people are we taking on the
trip like at that point maybe you need
two vehicles going cross country instead
of new york you just do a big loop just
do a 30 000 loop
when did you end up watching this video
10 minutes ago
[Laughter]
wait a minute
dude the video ends it's a good it's a
complete you're right it's a completely
different video is what it becomes but
the beauty is it ends with like a wad of
cash
from uber it's like this is leftover and
this pays for all the expenses it's like
a free road trip
nighty night
what's the time it is
is it mine time